trekking through this we River Forest
Preserve and Ghana is tough going but
these conservationists are on a mission
researcher Gilbert Adam is here with
some American colleagues on a quest to
find a particular species of frog which
he first discovered a few years ago not
this one but the Giants squeaker frog
it's thought there are only about 30 of
them left I have to be careful here have
we seen this frog today now that's
lovely well the same genus but Anna
d'etre a trollop is a different one by
so far as one is a good finds a great
find we spend sometimes a whole week or
two weeks every month here looking for
it for instance we started from June and
it was not on so the beginning of this
month so it took for mass and then we
found one here adam has devoted his
career to the giants wicker frog his
work on its behalf has sent him the
distant countries that is the sound of
the giants cricket frog I love frogs and
this laughs of frogs brought me to
jhemini brought me to Berlin to be
precise to the city's natural history
museum where Adam spent 18 months
conducting research the museum has a
collection of West African amphibians
and the Garnier and biologists also
learned to use a geographic information
system to produce maps how were the
giant squeaker frog and other frogs
native to Ghana coping with climate
change Adam received a fellowship grant
from the humboldt foundation to find out
my knowledge has improved drastically
there are about 80 frogs that okay in
Ghana almost all of them they have the
specimens and I've studied all of them
and now with the mouse that are
developed I know where each probe
a case so I've really benefited so much
I have never benefited from anything
more than this finish it now Adam is
back in Ghana continuing his research in
the sweet liver forest reserve this time
he doesn't manage to find a giant squid
frog but he does find a few pets left by
illegal gold prospectors anyway for the
tree frogs they can also come out
because they will need shows like this
or their struggle and if there's a
predator day the pro cannot be able to
escape the frogs natural habitat is also
threatened by logging Gilbert Adam shows
his colleagues from the US NGO save the
frogs the damage that's been wreaked by
the timber industry loggers are allowed
to fell just three trees per hectare
here but in fact they chop down a lot
more leaving devastated landscapes in
their wake s has been a war for us we
cannot fight them what we have been
doing is to educate the local people
that this forest is not for any timber
company it's not for the government is
for DD look out people the village of
your chrome is located on the edge of
the reserve if the sui forest and the
frogs that live in it are to survive the
inhabitants have to do their part they
depend on cocoa cultivation for their
livelihoods and also on honey production
does open day here they're being taught
how to build beehives and manage the
bees well yeah the project was initiated
by the Frog conservationists in the past
locals harvested honey in the wild with
fire but would burn down trees in the
process yo honey comb as I want the new
be keeping system is designed to protect
the forest you know what I can see
change is afoot in your Kron in another
project groan that was cleared to make
way for farmland is being replanted in
just a few years Gilbert Adam and his
organization have managed to enlist the
support of locals in protecting the
forest initially they didn't take his
work seriously and didn't see the point
of saving the frog and its habitat but
now they've helped plant 15,000
seedlings the palace is so vast so so
vast and if there are so many places
degraded see how far we came into the
forest and see the farms that have been
made and now the local people have
agreed that they will work with us we
should do the planting in the earth on
their farms so that later the trees will
take over
today the village of your chrome is
welcoming the community chief
schoolchildren are reciting poems to
mark the occasion I'm here to recite app
web title types of frogs types of frogs
there are many different types of frogs
value [ __ ] the celebration revolves
around the frogs and the frog
conservationists Gilbert Adam is even
awarded a special honor
I mana cabana boys unpinned FS I swear
allegiance ought to Yunan annum to help
in the development of your Chrome how
that made me the chief of the
environment environmental chief I've
never heard of an environmental chief in
Ghana or even West Africa so I may be
the first environmental chief across all
of West Africa and it's all because of
nothing else but frogs and the guys
quick a frog in particular the frog has
become a symbol of the community's
commitment to protecting their
environment